嗨大家好 我是马克洋
上一集我介绍了一种100%按下去就输钱的单
很多人就问我说
那如果我打反方向的单的话
是不是就变成一种会赢钱的单呢
答案是
不會
你打反方向的多单还是100%输钱的单
不过我们确实可以利用上一集学到的知识
做出有机会赚钱的操作
我们今天就来讲一讲这要怎么做
好 那我们先解释一下
就是上一集我讲了
这个右边的这一串交易成交名气
全部都是按下去
就是在送钱给别人的单
那当然他们按下去的时候
可能还以为自己在赚钱
就是具体他们搞不清楚交易规则的细节
你们可以自己去看上一集我有解释
好 那我解释一下
为什么你打反方向的单也不会赚钱
因为在主比撮合阶段
市场上的商品都是同时有两个价钱的
一个买价一个卖价
那买价跟卖价中间会差一个Tick
如果你要急着成交不管是急着买或急着卖的话
你都必须要让对方一个Tick的价钱
例如说现在你只能够用144.5马上买跟144元马上卖
那如果你是要希望用144元买到的话
你就只能挂在144元等着别人跟你成交
表示你不急嘛
那所以这个就是最基础的这个交易规则
如果比较多人急着买
那外盘成交就会比较多
那价钱就会往上上去嘛
那这个就是基本上就是股票这游戏规则的80%
就是最基础的基底最重要的规则就是这个规则
好吧
所以这个一定要搞清楚游戏规则
那我们讲一下这个我们要怎么样有机会真的因为上一集和这一集学到的知识赚钱呢
就是你在最后例如说剩10几分钟15分钟或是甚至剩半个小时的时候
你就去挂平均的价钱之上跟之下的买单跟卖单
那例如说在这个例如说1.15的时候
你在这个地方我们已经几乎确定会结算在144跟144.5之间了
那你去挂144的买单
因为144.5的卖单别人比较不会搞不清楚状况跟你成交嘛
因为看起来现货是在143
所以他们搞不清楚的方向应该是144这边
所以你就去挂144的买单
那真的会有很多人搞不清楚交易规则就跟你成交
我们上一集的影片也有稍微数了一下嘛
就是在1.14分之后还成交了1000多口的144买单
所以表示这个市场上搞不清楚游戏规则的人其实还是很多的
就是还是成交了1000多口
那我们可以看到下面还是挂了很多的单
像下面这个142.5还是挂了1000多口
不过这种单是不会赚钱的
就是挂那单只是在浪费自己的时间而已
因为根据交易的游戏规则
股票期货的结算价就不可能低于142.5
所以你挂142.5这个市场是不可能让你可以成交的
你挂144的意思就是说
会有一些人搞不清楚状况
然后送钱给我
那确实是有一千多口
那你挂142.5的意思就是说
必须要市场上全部的人都是笨蛋
才能够让这个股票期货打到跌停
而且还在跌停持续成交
就是基本上这个时候144的单还有机会赚钱
你看右边这一串成交迷信就在送钱给他们
但是下面的这些单就已经不会赚到钱了
因为不会让这个价钱往下打
那不过呢
当天实际上我是在长荣期货的次月
下个月的合约挂了142.5的跌停价
而且也实际上成交到了28口
那在第二天开高的时候
就是账面上未实现就已经达到赚30几万了
所以其实另一个做法是去挂次月
那具体上为什么我要这样挂
而且我要非常早挂
我在早上10点2分
就是这个股价还在152左右的时候
我就已经挂了我才有机会成交到
然后
所以在这个12点40分之后
我次月的这个跌停的长荣期次全部都被我全包下来
那好我下一集影片来讲一下这个我在次月当天的操作好了
这个上上上一集影片我就有所要讲嘛
不过我今天就先回答一下
很多人私讯问我这个有趣的问题
好就这样啦
我是马克洋
跟大家分享一个有机会赚钱的策略
好